ich habe meinen zuschauern gesagt sie
sollen ansagen an mich aufnehmen und
darauf reagiere ich heute bluecar du
bist scheiße
das hat mich sehr getroffen also
programmiert dass wir eine eigene pizza
haus gebracht und das ist total cool
weiße aber erstens schmeckt margareta
überhaupt nicht dass irgendwann bringe
ich eine pizza salami raus und die wird
tausende besser ist ein astreines okay
jaja ideen errichten und luca nicht zwei
alt 1 meter 99 meine freunde
wahrscheinlich bin ich zwei meter 1
meter 90 groß 104 und ich wieder 100
kilo ich meine vorhin war ich noch zwei
meter eigene 99 und jetzt bin ich
plötzlich so schnell kann sich meine
größe innerhalb von sekunden verändern
was dass ich hier ein übergewicht das
weiß auch eine krasse ansager mich wenn
wir einen knoblauch wären dann wärst du
denn auch
[Musik]
jahrhundert tut ist so geil
also wenn du dich ein knoblauch wären
dann wäre huhn das knop und ich der auch
das ist bisher die innovativsten sage du
bleistift
ich will also ein bleistift sohn
bleistift zu ich weiß ich weiß nicht was
du gegen bleistift da hast du aber ich
mag bleistifte die haben mich bei kunst
auch nicht viel weiter geholfen weil ich
da immer scheiße und war aber ich mag
bleistifte die editing skills sind da
auf jeden fall vorhanden und kann du
bist eigentlich vor der coole typen
sonne habe du stinkst einfach genauso
haben wie deine pizza
da hast du es mir jetzt aber gegeben ich
meinen job von meinen zuschauern sagen
wir so oft leute dass ich stinke ich
meine freunde wenn ich einfach ja wir
machen weiter und schwein aber du bist
kein schwein weil ich meine sie sind und
direkt die nächste person gesagt dass
ich denke dass die stadt hier ist rot
genauso gut wie du wirst wenn du ein
schwein sie zwar entspannt so süß ist
und du denkst ich will auch sie seien ja
so einfach ruhig lieber louis du stinkst
freute vielleicht kommt ja gleich doch
so innovative beleidigungen wie das ich
stinken würde
oder ich solle halt einfach mein maul
halten die beleidigung verstehe ich halt
doch so einfach gar nicht ich meine
diese sagt man leuten die solche maul
halten was machen sie dann darf luca ich
wollte dir nur kurz mitteilen wo nice
freude dass auch offen dazu sein zweites
video eingesendet ich bin cool und du
bist ein stuhl
[Musik]
hey du kannst du bist dumm
nee du bist der du bist umleitung du
dich nun bin ich also auch noch kritisch
ich weiß nicht wie eine person crash
sein kann weil sie dann eigentlich
quincy wäre aber ich bin anscheinend
clinch ich bin so leer wie diese
strohhalme wenn man von oben schaut dass
das macht definitiv sinn luca wende ich
mich endlich mal gut mache ich mitgehe
das was ich mit der takt offen das ist
irgendwie verstörend lukas borst zeig
mal was du hast da und nicht und ich
freue mich wie du dann liegt ein spaß
freunde das war ein mega gut hat das
sagte wir schauen uns das noch mal an
lukas zeig mal was du hast da und nicht
und ich freue mich wie du dann weg
bruder du hast du dich auf jeden fall
hart hoch gehören gerade an der stelle
wo ich das heute wieder auf beiden
beinen und händen ich werde jetzt heulen
gehen